now my next guest as he would say has
met and chatted with some of the most
significant people in politics show
business and sport
and he's now reliving those encounters
for a new radio show
i'm thrilled delighted to be able to
tell you that so michael parkinson
is joining us now hello to you
hi okay i've not seen you for ages my
dad except on telly
well it's always lovely to see you
whenever i can what made you decide
to do a new show i was
uh for many years now i've been fighting
a lone
cape crusader battle against those
ignorant people
in broadcasting who have written out my
favorite music namely jazz
so i don't know from jazz fm to do half
a dozen shows
and the first one went out last night
and i'm delighted they had a good sense
to do that
because it needs promoting that the
wonderful kosher
wonderful casket of music that's lying
there
uninterrupted by our main broadcasters
to tell the truth
uh there's absolutely criminal one of
the greatest uh creations of music in
all of music
and that's just certainly um he's being
made richard
so i know what my crew said yeah okay
well so michael my dad always used to
say that jazz is
13 men in a band all playing something
different
um why why was he wrong
uh well he's obviously
encompasses the great american songbook
as an example
and that is an imperishable important
uh body of music as important as any in
all of music
this is the point when you think of the
composers of the gershwins the original
hearts
and all those wonderful their music is
not
being heard is nothing short of criminal
and it's stupid
i mean god knows we've got enough
channels now blurting out
music that i find offensive quite
frankly so there's surely room for an
imperishable
what should be the creation which has
informed music for the past 100 years
and produced great artists like louie
armstrong and you've been gone forever
taxing archer ella fitzgerald come on i
would not
i want to compare any of the days people
who sing for a living with them
if so you're severely toned up
you're including some of your best bits
from some of your chat shows i think as
well aren't you uh sprinkling that
in that's part of the show you know you
know it's no good doing that show like
that i'm not actually bringing in some
of your heroes
and i did i interviewed with you know
duke ellington and that interview louis
armstrong
most of my heroes my musical heroes i
managed to get on the show
and uh they didn't let me down at all so
i played my part in what i've
considered to be a crusade to preserve
this music but i just wish you a more
encouragement to say from from major
broadcasters
such as skype well we're we've got you
on the telly right now sir michael um
what particular interviews from your
chat shows stick
in your mind well let me talk about the
ones that we had on the show i mean i
i had on on the show i had
uh what the names going on
how do you kill anything i'm fancy
forgetting duke ellington's name
i mean the most extraordinary man i mean
he has a chapter book all to himself in
any proper history of music and he was
wonderful and stylish and lovely and he
had
escalation of faded beauties
who followed him wherever he went in the
world and i got to them
after him when he was in the 60s and 70s
and so were they
it was a wonderful kind of collection of
past
romances and all that and he was a
deeply sort of um
much more romantic man as well and he
played a
sophisticated lady and he played take
the a train and all that and it's a bit
sit next to somebody who composed that
music
who has his own chapter his own book in
any history of music
proper history music it's just wonderful
and so
and we got to meet all my heroes i never
got to meet lily armstrong
was a particular hero of mine and i just
missed out on him
but uh so i mean by lucky you know and
and
those are the examples of the of the
or some of them of the um interviews
that i've drawn upon
in this series okay i mean that's the
deal they're still for lunch for another
time
sure i remember um when i first
sorry can i just say that
what i meant to say was that the the
other stuff
is contained in a documentary which is
going out uh this year
later on because this is the 50th
anniversary of the parkinson's show
50 years ago is when we started it so
michael my channel is my producer now
uh company uh he's doing a documentary
about that he's doing all the tips and
all that sort of stuff so
that should be coming out you know in a
month or two time so it's natural to
watch because there's one or two good
names on that
absolutely i remember um 30 odd years
ago when i was first starting out you
were very kind enough to take me under
your wing and one of your top tips which
i still do
is write whoever you're interviewing no
matter how famous they are write their
name on the top of the sheet
because you might forget their name and
you told me
that that happened with john wayne when
you were interviewing him
i did a good duke came into my mind but
i couldn't think what the next name
was uh but he didn't like me in any case
i didn't much care for him he was a
realtor
american gun lobby and all that sort of
stuff you know he really was i mean
he was like talking to her to share
started the demented sheriff
in a you know american big town you know
i'm not i'm not good i mean he was that
kind of man you know he was that kind of
american he was a typical of his
generation you know
gone law and all that sort of stuff
that's very simple
he was the sheriff you know and it was
fascinating to come across somebody that
dangerous as he was not as famous as he
was in many ways
wow jazz fm is where your new shows are
documentary later on in the year we are
out of time so michael but it's an
absolutely pleasure
hey it's on saturday night the show
started last night yeah absolutely
absolutely continues on for a few more
episodes and then your documentary later
in the year
it's good to talk to you so michael
absolute pleasure as always
okay thank you